SUBJECT: So there's an amazing
book called Drugs and Travel
in 20th Century Literature,
which makes the case that drugs
and travel are so discursively
entangled, so discursively
intimate, that we use
the same metaphors
and analogies to describe the
subjective experiences of each.
I mean even the
term hallucination
derives from the
Latin term [LATIN],
which means to
wander in our minds.
So when we are hallucinating,
we are travelling in our heads.
Why travel?
Well, the hero's journey, right?
This map that describes a
departure from the ordinary,
leaving normal thoughts
behind, treading forth
in the new environment
dealing with conflicts,
real ones or cognitive
ones, slaying the dragon,
solving the conundrum
in the existential itch,
and then making the return
with a new lesson learned.
Wandering in our minds and
taking the physical journey
both incorporate this motif of
transformation, an unfolding
that happens in time.
We cross over, I mean, implicit
in the term ecstatic drug
experience is this notion of
ecstasy, the non-static, right.
The pushing through,
the crossing over,
the breaking the threshold,
the piercing the veil.
The curtain parts and
what has never been seen
is devoured by the eyes.
We take a trip, we
call it tripping.
You see the analogies,
you see the parallels
these two discursively intimate
universes revealed to us
that the outer journey
and the inner journey
mirror each other.
In fact, there are
one in the same.
And I love that.
I love that because I
have the travelers itch,
I have the wanderlust.
I yearn for the holy other.
I look at the departure
monitors in the airport listing
all those destinations.
As Alain De Botton sites in
his book The Art of Travel,
we look upon those
screens and we
think to ourselves London,
Amsterdam, Prague, Berlin,
Mozambique, South
Africa, whatever
it may be, it's anywhere
else but here, right.
We long to crossover,
we long to experience,
to take the trip,
to take the journey.